[Musique]
alle alle c'est Moi caramella pour
devenir la reine
Desar ater 10 Ans Je m'entraîne Sur
s'en aller
deen la seule miss Sur Tous les
Terrain
caramella hé
joue
C'est mon génie de la maison Au pied
bénin
Oh pour conquérir le peuple espagnol
Je Me suis dit les vaches de la bricole
rb vers les Ares de cille tu pars
voler
par c'est nettement Plus optimiste c'est
Moi caramel
enfin et voilà meuve dans
laar mais aujourd'hui ce qui me gne
c'est pas le costume c'est le
taureau avant la corida j'en Ai Vu des
taureaux mais Vu de si près mon dieu mon
dieu que c'est
gros
alle dans Mon habit de lumi Je lui Ai
Fait les naz dans la poussi IL me
sourit mais pas que c'eau brav vi
chatouiller du bout de se mes de vach
Ah Non IL exag puis IL s'écrase sans
Manré Sur mois
doig va pas l'animal fait
mal
Au Je préfére ere Au lit oui c'est
[Musique]
Moi j'ai murmuré Adios Je Me sauve mais
poursuivi par le j'ai eu ses Corn Au bas
du
deux Au moment ou tu penses y aller
tomber en panne IL a dép sur une
banane
allez bonbon de torse je
[Musique]
M'avais je lve bras la posture était
Belle c'est ce
moment j'ai craqué mois bretelles
Mon pantalon Sur les talons j'ai
détérioration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]